[Music]
after the internet bubble burst in 2000
there was a period where the venture
capital industry retrenched and a void
was left the group of people saw an
opportunity there now known as the
PayPal mafia this was Peter Thiel Elon
Musk and Reed Hoffman they had two of
the most brilliant insights in the
history of entrepreneurship the first
was that the internet was about to make
a pivot from being a web of pages to a
web of people they called it web 2.0
this is what created the basis for all
of social networking the second insight
was probably even more powerful than
that it had turned out that for 50 years
before that time Silicon Valley had
basically struggled with the limits of
technology you never had enough
processing power memory storage or
bandwidth to do with the customer life
so every product had to address just a
piece of the customer problem the notion
of making a global product like Google
or Facebook never occurred to anyone
because she never had enough resources
to get it done the PayPal mafia realized
that Moore's law and met castle of the
to rule applause that talk about
processing power and networks were about
to hit crossing points where there would
be enough resources to do whatever you
wanted to do and it happened to coincide
exactly with their insight about web 2.0
they subscribed to a form of libertarian
as' and that basically not only praised
the individual but it it had this notion
that you could disrupt you could change
things and not be responsible for the
consequences of your actions which was
incredibly convenient if you're about to
go out and create giant global
enterprises the notion that you could
just knock things over and it was
somebody else's problem you know that
allowed you to do pretty much anything
this notion of blitzscaling
eliminating friction of all
so you can grow as rapidly as possible
to global scale and the problem of
eliminating friction if you eliminate
the ability of populations to adjust to
change things happen so quickly there's
no opportunity for evolution and these
guys went as you saw in a decade from
nothing to global and in 15 years they
went from nothing to global domination
they started with this notion that the
product had to be free you had to get
rid of the friction of a purchase price
so if you're gonna have a free product
it's got to be supported by advertising
and if you want to have advertising be
valuable people had to pay attention
they got into this notion that they
would manipulate attention first with
rewards to create habits they would give
you likes they would give you
notifications to get you to come back
and they would build habits that for
many people turned into addictions but
the other thing they did was when they
got you there they appealed to the
lizard bring the low level flight or
fight emotions that caused people to
become tribal they peeled to outrage and
fear why because when you're afraid or
when you are outraged you share the
source of that fear outrage with other
people because if they share that with
you that emotion you're gonna feel
better and that worked really really
well it caused people to share a lot of
stuff and see lots of ads if they'd stop
there we probably would have been okay
what they didn't Google had a brilliant
insight in 2003 actually they had it
earlier they patented in 2003 this
notion of behavioral prediction what
Google discovered was that the data they
captured from their users that they used
to improve the search engine they
captured tons of data that nothing to do
with improving the search engine but
they discovered it told him a lot about
what people were gonna do it gave them a
way to predict behavior
traditionally business has collected
data to improve a product or sir
is for the person from whom they
collected the data but behavioral
prediction is practiced first by Google
then by Facebook and now also by Amazon
and I believe by Microsoft is really
about taking data from one person and
applying it to somebody else so the
person whose data is used gets no
benefit they could use persuasive
technology to increase the probability
of the prediction would be accurate
which would make it more valuable let me
give you an example let's say you're
gonna buy a car you buy a car they look
at the 200 steps you take before you
bought the car to see what are the
things you do before you buy a car and
maybe 10 or 20 of them are about buying
a car but we'll assume that all this
stuff but if they compare enough people
they discover all kinds of patterns from
things that don't appear to have
anything to do with a car but are
actually lead indicators that you're
going that way and then they take that
and they can price they can make
predictions based on where you are in
those 200 steps so if you make the first
20 that doesn't mean anything
but if you make the first hundred and 50
the probability you're gonna buy a car
is pretty high if you make the first
hundred and eighty if you're on that
curve after one hundred and eighty the
odds that you're gonna buy a car is
really high and at one ninety it's
almost a certainty so the price becomes
exceptionally high if they stop there
that would be great but they didn't they
used filter bubbles which is to say
their ability to nudge people by
confirming pre-existing beliefs and they
used recommendation engine to increase
the probability that their forecasts
would be accurate so when you go in
there and you see a recommendation and
you think to yourself well this thing is
helping me find things I'm gonna like
maybe but for certain it's helping you
find things that the person would like
to sell you and now we're starting to
get into really problematic areas and
when you watch this business model go to
its final point they're tracking
everything so they go out there and they
buy all your credit card information and
they go and buy all your location
information from from the cellular
carrier
and if there's health apps that they can
get data from they get that they buy
data wherever they can get it they
create this really high-resolution
picture of you but they're also tracking
what you do maybe you've been on one of
those CAPTCHA things that Google has to
identify whether you're a human or not
and they show you can you pick out the
road signs that has nothing to do with
are you a human or not that's to train
Google's self-driving car they've
figured out if you're a human based on
the way you move your mouse guess what
they're keeping a file of all your mouse
movements over time and I don't know if
they can do this yet but pretty soon
they're gonna be able to tell if you
have a neurologic problem before you
even know it so your mouse slows down
maybe gets more shaky maybe you've got
the beginning of Parkinson's now here's
the problem if you were their customer
they would call you up and say hey
you've got to go to a hospital but
you're just the fuel for their business
the customer is going to be the
insurance company that'll pay them
thousands of dollars to know that you
haven't in the beginnings of a
neurologic problem which would allow
them either to raise your insurance
rates or terminate your in coverage
entirely I would like to think that we
could have a national conversation about
did we sign up for this and you know the
questions I want to ask is why is it
legal that there is commerce based on
our personal financial transactions
credit cards mortgages and things like
that why is it actually legal for people
to trade in that information same
question for geolocation data from
cellular carriers or map products why is
that legal why is it legal to have
commerce in health data from apps and
devices it's not legal to have commerce
in the stuff from hospitals or doctors
these things aren't happening cuz these
companies are bad people they're
happening because there are no rules
nobody told them to stop they're really
smart it's obviously a great business
and so my basic point here is
I think we should stop have a serious
conversation figure out as a country
what are we gonna do about this
[Music]